[Music]
our relationship to nature
is uh
undergoing some significant change the
question is just how we think about that
change uh and how we think about
ourselves in relationship to nature so
i'd like to just move on from that
background question to the specifics of
some of the situations that we find
ourselves in so
should we see this move towards seeing
nature as a god as potentially a
dangerous step
that undermines human values tim
well i think there is a potential danger
um and and i perhaps would even sort of
draw on two things that were said just
now
um
you know you you
you were talking about the amazon and
how the bulldozers came in and sort of
destroyed the system and although
already that puts a picture in your mind
of this sort of man-made technology
destroying the natural
system and i think peter also said you
know we're not going to solve our
problems by technological fixes
and i certainly agree we're not going to
solve them by technological fixes alone
but
science and technology i mean the danger
with
you know peter you were talking about
how
einstein was rejected by his jewish
religious uh
people and of course galileo and so on
so there there's always this tension
between
uh
religion and theology and science and
technology it doesn't have to be
intention but historically it's always
been
i think we cannot ignore
science and technology
uh
in facing the current particularly
environmental problems
um
let me just give you i mean it's
terribly practical but let me give you
an example because there's a colleague
of mine peter edwards at the university
of oxford
he's working on
an ability to take waste plastic
bombard it with microwave energy and and
basically rip the chemical
bonds apart and create hydrogen and sort
of pure carbon
okay so now what could you do with this
well hydrogen i'm sure people are aware
is a is a potential
energy vector energy source if you like
for replacing gas and oil and and
petrol and so on
so one proposal that we've made is that
you could actually make steel you will i
think you know you've heard in the news
about the the coking coal plant in in
the in the lake district which is there
to make coal make sorry make steel
coking coal to make steel
well okay we can do this with waste
plastic if we use
this technology we have the hydrogen to
heat the iron ore
we then add the carbon from the plastic
into the iron ore to make steel so
suddenly we've got a green way of making
steel this is technology
solving one of you know steel is what we
need to make buildings there are many
examples of this
so we we shouldn't
you know we shouldn't
automatically tar science and technology
uh as as bad and the sort of you know
the natural
world the god of of the earth or
something is inherently good
there's got to be a synergy here
moving forward and it's clearly
something which takes advantage of our
special
status as a highly creative
um species to do that so that that you
know so i'm not
against
what you're saying but i think there is
a sort of a danger
that
elevating
nature to this theological status there
is a danger that people will
automatically then reject science and
technology as a solution for our
problems and i think that would be a
mistake okay i'll just come to peter in
a moment melanie uh
i mean in bangladesh the supreme court
uh
gave rights to all rivers
and one of the consequences of that were
that farmers and fishers were
immediately
asked to move from where they were and
they lost their livelihoods
so
do you think there's a danger in
in uh putting
nature up as having rights independently
of us or do you think that is the right
move and it was a right thing for those
uh
farmers and fishers to have to move
i think
you know
it's imperfect you know that is the
nature of the world that we have that
has been gifted us if you like um
by the chaos of of
of physics or whatever you want today or
a god however you want to view it
um we've inherited something as people
and and nature is absolutely
a mixed bag in terms of outcomes we're
living right now we've all been talking
behind the scenes about how weird it is
to all be here i'm sure some of you
might be feeling the same way it's the
first time i've come and talked to
anyone live for like a year and a half
so
all of us are a little bit raw because
we're living in a pandemic well viruses
are a key part of nature my child was
asking me the other day you know what
say
where the viruses live and i we were
right by the sea because i lived by the
sea and i said well they're mostly in
there there are millions and millions
and millions of them in there and
they've partly given us perhaps had a
role in multicellularity so this thing
that is seen as horrible and frightening
that we need to eliminate is a key part
of nature and it sometimes does things
that are unpleasant including to us so
nothing's a given in nature but i think
to go back to the concrete again about
being in in
no wonder given that that we have sought
belief systems that help us through
the moral and psychological
stresses that follow from that kind of
chaotic nature
nonetheless the reality is we have to
get down to some pragmatics when you are
in the situation where and very often at
the moment what we're seeing is sticking
plasters going over all of these things
so
in rights of nature's cases so what we
might call wild law
we're seeing that coming out of
indigenous rights movements quite often
people who were historically
disenfranchised from the land who have
had no political voice whatsoever
who've often had you know been subject
to land grabs who are just getting by at
the edges of of
any given state or nation who is
starting to come back and say well
what you're describing in the world
isn't our world view that's not how we
situate ourselves with our resources
it's not how we manage our resources and
we want a political voice
and you know you can completely
understand no matter what you might
think about it philosophically you can
see historically how that's come about
and it's solving that kind of historical
mess
but then you've got the situation with
the bulldozers and i absolutely hear you
and i i mean i'm i'm a total science
consumer of science you know
and i think science has a lot to do in
giving us very good reasons to act and
it will have a lot to do in resolving
problems
i mean creating things if you look at
industrial history can go any which way
you can end up with cfcs that you never
saw coming in a big hole in the ozone
you can also fix the problem thereafter
or use science to understand the problem
and and track its
uh
its amelioration over time which is you
know what's happening in the antarctic
so we need all of the tools available
but we always have to understand that
the reason we're doing something is
based on our value framework and it's
those value frameworks i think that we
really need to make sense of okay thank
you so peter um what do you say to those
people who say this this move to seeing
nature is god is is dangerous it's a
threat to human agency it's a threat to
our values
what do you say to
them um
well
maybe it is a threat
i mean maybe an egocentric point of view
is a threat to humanity because
it puts if we really are to put humanity
on a par with nature then we have got no
right to think of ourselves as special
this is dangerous to human beings but
but one could say
helpful to nature as a whole so there is
there is certainly a conflict i would
not doubt it
um for example population control yeah
so so you'd say uh yeah it's dangerous
to human beings but uh that's that's
it's the right thing to do well no i'd
say it depends on uh it really comes
down to theory of morality does it not
so
do you value um an anthropocentric um
morality essentially where values are
placed
on top as
of the most value or do you take an
egocentric
morality
um now of course people can take their
personal perspectives on this but is
there any theoretical way in which to
distinguish but you're but but as i
understand it you think that
we we should be
uh seeing uh nature
i i think i think we have um following
our christian legacy in the west
and the you know right from the
judeo-christian legacy seeing
you know
the universe created for man you know in
genesis and so on um as having dominion
over the earth there has always been
intrinsically subconsciously this
valuation of humanity above nature
nature's made for us okay we're stewards
of it as well but essentially we are on
top
and this
undercurrent has
um
flown through
um
many moralities until hans jonas like i
said says we need to think about more
eco-centric values
how do you how do you ground values how
do you make this balance
uh this is an interesting question
i mean for spinoza i'm not saying i
agree with spinoza here but essentially
ultimately might is right
so
what people value is what's good for
them and if they can control a place
then they will do that and the values
will reflect that
the question really is are do there
exist transcendent values an ideal good
towards which we could understand
whether anthropocentrism as opposed to
egocentrism um
is is right or wrong now spinoza of
course was not a transcendentalist god
was nature there was nothing outside of
nature
so ultimately i would say that if you
my argument would be if you want to
value humanity above anything else in
nature you have to make a very
good
argument for there being some form of
transcendent evaluation where do you
stand on that though i think there is no
transcendent valuation okay therefore
there is no answer there's no there's no
fact of the matter as to whether
anthropocentric as opposed to ecocentric
values are better or worse this is like
tea or coffee there's there's no fact of
the matter what's better i would say
though as a human myself obviously i
have a subjective preference for
you know saving my fellow
uh humans um but i see that as
subjective
ultimately there's no there's no fact of
the matter okay
so
yeah what could i i mean
it seems to me it's a slightly false
dichotomy this anthropo versus
eco-centric because what we understand
now is that the biosphere
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas